but you Kyle Bevan murdered her when she
was only two years old and Eugene James
allowed her death
her death has shattered a family
including the childhood of her surviving
sisters
no one who listened to the victim
personal statements in court today could
fail to be profoundly moved by them
in 2020 Sinead James lived as a single
mother in Haverford West with her three
daughters a baby born in May 2019 Lola
born in September 2017 and her older
sister born in March 2014.
Kyle Bevin was not the father of any of
these children but very soon after he
met Sinead James in February 2020 he was
sleeping in her house every night and
when lockdown started in March 2020 it
was his home
I'm sure from the evidence at trial that
Kyle was responsible for multiple
assaults on the children before he
murdered Lola
well it's the evidence of some in
isolation would have been inconclusive
taken together it is compelling
a 2 am text on the 19th of April 2020
shows that one of the girls had smashed
her face which Kyle blamed on the stairs
on the 26th of April Sinead James
noticed a mark under Lola's mouth
Kyle blamed it on her falling down
a text at 1 35 a.m on the 4th of May
shows that Lola was screaming when Kyle
was with her
the next day he told Sinead James that
Lola dropped to the floor and bit her
lip
the text record shows that Sinead saw
Lola spitting at Kyle and making what he
described as a horrible noise at him
I have no doubt that this was because
Lola was protesting as a child who could
not yet speak the abuse she had suffered
on the 10th of May 2020
light switch
overnight but she brought them back the
next day
a few days later Sinead James's cousin
pointed out the dirty messy state of the
house and warned her social services
might get involved
Kyle was angry and aggressive about that
suggestion
on the 8th of June 2020 Sinead James
lied to her health visitor on the
telephone that she had a female person
sleeping in her house covering up that
it was actually Carl Bevan
on the 11th of June Sinead texted I'm
done and I'm finished with Kyle
he had grabbed her arm during an
argument
she texted I'm not putting up with it I
have the kids to think about
but she let it pass and he carried on
living in the house with the children
and was often left in Soul charge of
them
on the 5th of July Sinead and Carl
argued and she told him to get out
she texted him what you are doing is a
form of domestic violence I know I've
been through it he refused to leave the
house and she took it no further
on the 7th of July 2020 Carl Bevin
pushed the pram into a busy road with
the baby in it
on the 9th of July the grandmother of
Kyle's own daughter messaged Sinead
James that he had been abusive to his
ex-partner and their daughter and
expressed concern that he was around
Sinead James's children
Sinead asked Kyle's mother about it who
said it was not true
she made no other inquiry and took no
steps to withdraw or protect her
children from Kyle
on the same day Lola suffered a nose
injury and Sinead wondered if it was
broken
Kyle told her Lola had fallen
accidentally onto a coffee table
he blamed the dog
at the same time two witnesses noticed
marks on either side of Lola's neck
which suggested she had been grabbed or
pinned
the witness elevar Morgan had a look and
told Sinead and Kyle she should be taken
to the doctor
but Sinead lied and said that had
already been done
in fact all that had happened according
to her evidence at trial was that she
had been told by Kyle that his mother
was a nurse which was not true although
she was a health care assistant and that
she had looked at Lola's injured nose in
a video call
Lola was not taken to a hospital or to a
doctor or examined in person by a nurse
or any qualified person
her nose was left to heal in its own way
the very next day on the 10th of July
when Kyle was alone with the baby Sinead
texted him you don't need to tell me
what you're doing with them I do trust
you with them
on the 11th of July texts show that
there was some sort of incident when
Lola was in Kyle's care but Sinead
texted him don't feel bad
I am sure
that by the time of the murder Sinead
knew that Kyle was not to be trusted
on the 16th of July the day before Lola
was beaten into a coma she asked him for
his date of birth so she could do a
Claire's law or domestic violence
disclosure scheme check on him
he refused to give it to her
she realized that was suspicious but she
did not press it
that night
the night of the 16th to 17th of July
Sinead James was woken at midnight by a
bang followed by Lola screaming
she got up and saw Kyle Bevin holding
Lola by her bed
but when he said I've got this
she just went away
she did not go into Lola's bedroom or
have a proper look at what had happened
she went back to her own bed
and left Lola alone with Kyle while she
slept
during that night he carried out the
further attacks on Lola which killed her
by 4 26 am Kyle had Lola downstairs and
was photographing injuries he had
inflicted on her back
by 6 30 a.m he had inflicted a total of
over 100 visible injuries all over her
body
some of them were caused by a weapon
although the weapon used was not
recovered or identified
they included injuries to Lola's right
thigh with circular elements in a linear
pattern caused by a weapon
and bleeding puncture wounds to her
forehead also caused by a weapon
Kyle Bevin hit the side of Lola's head
with such force that it caused ear
bruising and subdural bleeding in her
skull on that side
he shook her head backwards and forwards
so violently that she lost consciousness
and died from brain damage
Dr Michelle Jardin is a consultant in
Pediatric Intensive Care who has worked
in Wales for 12 years and before that at
Great Ormond Street and at the Royal
Brompton Hospital
she saw Lola's body in intensive care
and gave evidence that it was one of the
most extensively bruised and battered
bodies she had ever seen
at 6 30 am
Kyle Bevan searched on Google
my two-year-old has just taken a bang to
the head and gone all limp and snoring
what's wrong
the results told him to get emergency
help at once
had he done that Lola would have had a
better chance of survival
but he didn't
he didn't get emergency help
he didn't wake Lola's mother
instead he tried to cover his tracks
he cleaned up Lola's vomit and blunt in
the bath
he cleansed the bath
he cleans the floors he scrubbed the
body itself all over so strongly
despite the child already being injured
and unconscious
that temporary transfer tattoos on her
arms were removed without Trace
he put clean clothing on her
he dreamed up a cover story that all
Lola's injuries were attributable to a
fall down the stairs after a push from
the dog
he moved Lola's body around
callously photographing it and even
filming it at one stage
half an hour after the Google search his
mother woke up and saw texts he had been
sending her
she immediately texted back that he must
wake Sinead James up and get Lola to
accident and emergency
it was 6 56 am
even then he did not wake up Lola's
mother or call Emergency Services
he was too concerned about covering up
the crime scene to do anything at all
for the child
it was only half an hour after that at
about 7 27 am that he finally woke
Sinead James
and not having called an ambulance
himself
told his mother to do it
ambulances were then called by his
mother and by Sinead James and were on
the scene immediately
when the police came later in the
morning at about 11 am
he delayed opening the front door
when they did get in he was still vacuum
cleaning away as much forensic evidence
as he could
there is only one sentence for murder
and that is imprisonment for life
I must also set the minimum term that
Carl Bevin must serve before he can even
be considered for release on license by
the parole board it is possible he will
never be released as that will happen
only if and when the parole board is
satisfied that detention is no longer
necessary for the protection of the
public
that is why it is called a minimum term
even if he is released he will remain on
license and be subject to recall to
prison for the rest of his life
the minimum term is not his sentence
his sentence is life imprisonment
pain due regard to schedule 21 of the
sentencing act and reflecting the
particular circumstances of the case I
am adopting 15 years as the starting
point for consideration of the minimum
term but there are aggravating features
which must very significantly increase
it
Lola was a very young child two years
and 10 months old
she was particularly vulnerable not
being strong enough to resist or old
enough to tell anyone what was happening
Kyle Bevin was in a position of trust
having assumed the role as he described
himself to the ambulance crew of Lola's
stepfather
he started to hurt Lola at midnight and
he carried on until she was unconscious
at 6 30 am
he did not stop when Sinead James nearly
caught him in the act when she heard
Lola scream at midnight
this was a sustained deliberate and very
violent attack
the attack was completely unprovoked
there is no suggestion that Lola was
playing up in any way before she was
killed
for some of the injuries Kyle Bevin used
weapons
the attack would have caused both mental
and physical pain and suffering before
the onset of coma
it was the culmination of several months
of physical child abuse
although I have decided that this is not
a case within paragraph 2 2B of schedule
21. I am sure that Kyle Bevin did this
as an exercise of power
an assertion of superiority over the
only person he could feel Superior to
a helpless child
afterwards he covered up what he had
done by removing or replacing the
weapons and cleaning up the body and the
crime scene before getting help
he ignored advice from his mother about
getting immediate help
as soon as the police were involved he
tried to rehearse his partner in a false
account which he had concocted stressing
to her you got to get it bang on like
he has no remorse at all even now
at the time he did not even simulate
sadness about Lola's injuries and
critical condition when everyone around
him was distraught at the hospital he
threatened and insulted the staff
he heard abuse at the victim's natural
father and challenged him to a fight for
no reason at all as Lola Lay Dying in
critical care
he was openly concerned only about
himself
the serious and numerous aggravating
features raised the appropriate minimum
term far above the starting point of 15
years
I now turn to mitigating or potentially
mitigating factors
there is very little
Kyle Bevan did not specifically intend
to kill
but he was completely Reckless of the
danger to Lola's life
the violence he inflicted all over her
body including the severe and fatal
attacks on her head both by way of blunt
force and violent shaking were a threat
to the life of such a young child which
must have been obvious to him
he has been described by his own mother
as thick and was diagnosed with ADHD as
a child
I am satisfied that these points do not
reduce Carl bevin's culpability
he was 28 years old and perhaps immature
but he knew exactly what he was doing
he had no previous convictions for
violence but he had been causing visible
injuries to the children on the sly for
a number of months
this murder was the worst thing he had
done but it was not out of character
this is a very serious case in which the
balance of features I've identified
moves the appropriate minimum term a
long way up from the 15-year starting
point
I now turn to Sinead James conviction
for allowing the death of a child
her relationship with Lola's biological
father had been brief and he was a
loving and attentive parent to Lola from
a distance however she came into the
relationship with Kyle Bevan as a victim
of past domestic abuse from other
partners
as a result she had been trained through
domestic abuse programs to protect
herself and her children but she allowed
Kyle Bevin into her household on the
basis of a superficial initial
impression
as evidence against him began to mount
she continued to hope for the best and
leave her children at risk
she was surrounded by supportive friends
and family
she was connected with social services
she always had places of Refuge
but she shut her eyes to the very
obvious danger which Carl Bevin posed to
her children even after she saw him
deliberately pushed the pram into
oncoming traffic
she decided to accept and manage the
risk to herself
and more importantly her helpless
children because he was not as bad as
her previous abusers and she liked
having him there
she prioritized the relationship with
Kyle Bevan over concern for her children
this was never more evident than when
she went back to bed after the scream
and the bang which she heard from Lola's
bedroom when Lola was with Kyle only
hours before Lola was murdered
I will apply the sentencing guideline
for allowing a child to die
harm is death and therefore category 1.
culpability includes failing to protect
Lola from a murder which involved the
use of very significant Force
all four quadrants of both Lola's eyes
were bleeding at multiple levels there
was a retinal fold and retinal splitting
there was optic nerve sheath bleeding to
both eyes
these are all signs of very severe Force
Lola had widespread petechiai she had
subdural bleeding mainly over the left
cerebral hemisphere but also at the back
of the right cerebral Hemisphere and
also at the base of her brain
this was due both to very forceful
shaking and significant impact injury to
the left which also caused bruising to
her left ear
further evidence of impact was the soft
tissue scalp swelling at several sites
over Lola's skull
the chronology shows that Sinead James
was made aware of multiple injuries to
her children leaving visible marks and
also a threat to the life of the baby in
her pram which Sinead knew was Carl
bevan's fault she knew he had taken a
hammer to the light switch was subject
to mood swings and was prone to take
recreational drugs which had a bad
effect on him specifically Xanax in
combination with alcohol
she showed herself willing and able to
remove her children to a place of safety
and to demand that Kyle Bevan should
leave the house
but she always brought the children back
and kept leaving them in his soul care
when her children were injured she did
not take them to a doctor or to hospital
and she did not involve the police when
Kyle was violent
she did not disclose the presence of
Kyle or the injuries to her children to
Social Services although they were in
active contact with her
so she failed to take any effective
steps to protect Lola including those
which she had proved she was capable of
these are features of high culpability
in category B
there are no category D factors
Sinead James was on antidepressant
medication but it was working well for
her
responsibility was not reduced
substantially or at all
by mental disorder learning disability
or lack of maturity
although she had been a victim of
domestic abuse this was not in my
judgment linked to the commission of the
offense
she was able to assert herself against
Carl Bevin and did so
she was neither coerced nor intimidated
into allowing Kyle to carry on living in
her house
she was happy to leave him alone with
the children whenever he wanted and that
however long he wanted that was her
choice
having heard all the evidence including
her own evidence at trial
and her police interviews
I do not think that this is a case in
which Sinead James allowed the death of
her child because she was in fear of
Kyle bethan or a victim of domestic
abuse by him
that was not even her own evidence at
trial
I do not accept the defense submission
that the domestic abuse is linked to the
commission of the offense so as to
provide her with a category D feature
I do accept that when he was in a bad
mood Kyle Bevin was intimidating
but these moods passed and most of the
time the text messages and the evidence
at trial show a relationship in which
Sinead James was in control and able
when she chose to remove herself and her
children from Kyle Bevan and to berate
him when she thought he deserved it the
only thing that she did hesitate to do
because of his reaction was to contact
the police or the social services
she always had full recourse to her
friends her neighbors and her family and
that was enough to protect the children
if she had chosen to do it
she did not
for example she insisted against the
advice of Casey Morgan on bringing the
children back into the home after the
pram incident when they were already
with that in safety it was no part of
her evidence that she did this because
she was in fear of Kyle Bevan
having considered all the category
indicators in the sentencing guideline
and after a careful balancing exercise I
am satisfied that this case falls into
category B1 with a starting point of
nine years custody in a range of 7 to 14
years however
I notice that the applicable sentence in
guidelines sets ranges up to 18 years in
category A1 which is above the statutory
maximum of 14 years for this case in
which the offense was committed before
the 28th of June 2022
since when the maximum has been life
imprisonment I will bear that in mind in
Sinead James favor when arriving at a
sentence in accordance with the
guideline
a potentially aggravating factor is her
failure to respond to warnings about
Kyle and his behavior
she was warned by her best friend Casey
Morgan and by the grandmother of Carl
bevan's own child
but I recognize that Casey Morgan also
at times seemed to support the
relationship with Kyle
and that his mother emphatically assured
her that the allegations against her son
were lies
there are weighty mitigating factors
she is very remorseful as I saw when she
gave evidence
she is also genuinely devastated by
Lola's death
she has lost custody of her surviving
children although she remains in contact
with them
after Lola's death Sinead James
cooperated as fully as she possibly
could with the investigation
she has no previous convictions and
nothing else which is relevant on her
record
she is a victim of previous domestic
abuse and Kyle Bevan did create an
atmosphere of intimidation in the home
at times which I accept as a mitigating
feature even though I have decided it
does not go so far as to be a category D
guideline feature
taking everything into account the
sentence will be below the starting
point and a little below the bottom of
the category B1 guideline range
Kyle Bevan has already spent 368 days in
custody on remand Sinead James has spent
19 days the days spent on remands in
custody will automatically count towards
the custodial term of her sentence and I
will deduct them from the minimum term
for his
Sinead James will serve one half of her
sentence in custody before being
released on license
when she is released she will be on
license until the end of her sentence
she must comply with the terms of the
license and commit no further offense or
else she will be liable to serve a
further period in custody
each defendant must pay the statutory
surcharge of 190 pounds or such other
correct figure as may be substituted
administratively
stand up combat
for the murder of Lola James I sentence
you to imprisonment for life with a
minimum term of 28 years less 368 days
already spent in custody on remand you
may go down
stand up Sinead James
for allowing the death of Lola James I
sentence you to six years imprisonment
you will serve half namely three years
before release on license
you may go down